- It's gonna be great.
It's gonna be awesome.
We're gonna have a blast.
Come on, let's bring it in.
Bring it in.
Let's get a picture.
all: Fowling!
[camera shutter clicks]
[pins clatter]
[upbeat music]
- Hey, how are ya?
We're here for
the charity event.
- The entry is a suggested
$100 donation.
- And I would suggest
a much lower number.
[both laugh]
Is there an open bar?
- Yes.
- Oh! [blows raspberry]
You're gonna lose money
on this deal.
- It's dumb, stupid.
- This is dumb.
You guys are suckers.
- Idiots.
- Here you go, sucker.
- Thank you.
- Oh, there's Harbaugh.
[scattered groans]
- Dang it!
- It's okay, Jim.
We're just having fun,
for charity.
- Well, it's totally
different mechanics.
Fowling is different.
You think LeBron James
would be good at pop-a-shot?
Look at this guy!
I'm getting this.
Dang it!
This guy's killing me!
- There she is.
[Harbaugh grunts]
Let's do it.
[upbeat funky music]
♪ ♪
- Oh, yum-yum-yum.
This looks delicious.
I can't wait
to have another slice.
- Uh, s-sorry,
you each have a--
a pepperoni on your face.
- Oh, God damn it.
- [groans]
- Oh, crap.
- How embarrassing.
First we donate
$10,000 to charity,
and now we got
pepperoni on our faces.
- [soft laugh]
I'm sorry.
You probably get this
all the time,
but has anybody ever told you
you look just like--
- Emma Stone.
- [tsks]
- No.
I was thinking Reilly Clair, VP
of Marketing, Little Caesars.
- Oh, actually, yeah,
I am Reilly Clair.
Yeah.
- Oh, my goodness..
[both laugh]
- Are you serious?
- That's--I mean--
so embarrassing.
- Oh, my God.
- First, we donate 10K.
Each.
- Each.
- And now this? Ugh.
Sam Duvet.
Cramblin Duvet Advertising.
- Hi.
- Yeah. How you doing?
Tim Cramblin,
the aforementioned
Cramblin Duvet Advertising.
We would love to
work with you someday.
- Oh, well, actually we are
looking for a new agency.
- Oh, my God.
I had not heard that.
Sam, had you heard that?
- I had not heard that.
- Oh, had I heard that
I would have said,
"Well, look no further
You found
the perfect guys for the job."
Had I heard that.
- Had he heard that.
- Dang it!
Give me that.
Watch this.
[yells]
- I don't mind telling you,
we're the two best
admen in the city.
But we're also big fans
of your Little Caesar's pizza.
- Oh, thank you.
- The smell of one of
your Hot-N-Readys instantly
takes us back to some of our
greatest childhood memories.
- And not just for us,
but for everyone we know.
- [wails]
- You couldn't walk
50 miles in any direction
from the spot
we're standing in right now
without coming across
a birthday party,
graduation,
or an anniversary
that isn't serving
a great, big, piping-hot...
- I can't believe this!
- Little Caesars...
[ball thunks]
[woman gasps, man groans]
- Pizza, pizza.